the sooner you teach values  later on if this kid wants to go sell  cocaine and go become a drug addict and  do whatever he wants to do or she wants  to do that part's on them you can't  teach the right values and principles  after 18. it's very hard it's not  received the same way as you teach it  early on so the sooner somebody teaches  you the right habits the sooner you have  an edge the later somebody teaches like  for example insurance industry if I were  to tell you haven't been in this  industry for 21 years that's going to be  21 years September the people that gave  us the most problems when they came in  were people that came in who left three  other insurance companies and we would  sit there would look at and say why are  we having so many problems with these  guys well they brought bad habits from  another insurance company the people  that we train ourselves we have the  least amount of issues with because  they're learning how to sell the proper  way